so we seem to be charging headfirst into
something here and there aren't very
many people interested in slowing down
the process unfortunately I think a lot
of people are interested more in
speeding it up Joaquin Castro a Democrat
congressman brother of Julian Castro
who's one of the guy one of the
one-percenters running for one percenter
in the poll that is might be one
percenter financially - I'm not sure
Julian Castro running for president well
this is his brother who decided to find
and post the names and employers of
trumps biggest donors in San Antonio
Castro represents San Antonio so he was
doing this to his own constituents you
know you send someone to Congress to
represent your interests but instead
he's he's daxing his own constituents
this now you can argue as some leftists
have argued that well this is publicly
available information so it's not like
they he was rooting through their junk
mail or something in there it's publicly
available and okay fine it is but what's
the point of putting those names out
there what's the point of doing it the
fact that it's public okay a lot of
things are public but why why are you
putting it out there for people the
names the contact information telling
people okay here's where you can find
them here's where they work in this
environment what's the point of doing
that with violence on both sides
becoming more and more common what could
possibly be the point other than to
stoke violence against Trump's donors I
mean look what happened to Mitch
McConnell he injured himself he broke
his shoulder I think and while he was
recovering at his house far-left
activists showed up at his house in the
middle of the night to protests
quote/unquote protest him one of them is
it says on camera that she hopes someone
will come and here's a quote from her
just stab the mother effer in the heart
and and of course Democrats say they've
done nothing to discourage this in fact
it was I think was Barbara Boxer who
made a made a
funny witty little quip about how Mitch
McConnell must have broke his shoulder
tripping over a copy of the Constitution
that he left laying around and that
something like that now it goes without
saying okay it goes without saying that
if Donald Trump had made a joke like
that about an injured Democrat imagine I
mean just imagine that Alexander Kaiser
Cortes broke her shoulder in some sort
of accident and then Donald Trump on
Twitter made a joke about it mate not in
just a joke but a taunting joke that's a
five day news cycle easily but of course
with Republicans it's it's just a it's a
it's just the way it goes I suppose
same thing with Rand Paul you know he
was assaulted by his neighbor a couple
years ago he announced over the weekend
that he had that part of his lung
removed from the injuries he sustained
in that assault and if you go on Twitter
and you look at that tweet that Rand
Paul sent out just saying hey I had that
part of my lung removed so I'm gonna be
kind of out of commission for the next
few weeks
almost every common thousands of
comments in a row taunting him for it
Ilhan Omar retweeted a tweet now this
was before we knew he was removing part
of his long but last week she were
tweeted it to a tweet mocking Rand Paul
for being assaulted this is this is
where we are now a lot of what we're
seeing now a lot of the rhetoric being
used would have been unthinkable five
years ago even just five years forget
about ten or twenty years just five
years ago this would have been
unthinkable and and now it's it's now
it's all part and parcel and here's what
makes it even worse in my view as some
you know prominent voices on the left
and on the right seem to encourage
violence encourage more chaos you know
they aren't doing it really because they
specifically want violence and that's
the I'm not making an excuse for them
okay it's actually worse than that to to
intentionally foment violence because
you want violence to try to whip up a
mob against someone simply because you
hate them that's bad enough
I mean that's bad that's really bad I
think this is even worse this goes back
to what I've been talking about over the
past few days
this just disregard for human life it's
it's it's not even hatred it's it's
actually lower than hatred hatred is
better it's bad but it's better than
what we're seeing in our culture now
which is people who have disregard for
each other it just doesn't matter and
those who are who are throwing red meat
into this mob they're doing it just to
get in the headlines to get attention
they're doing it because it's
politically expedient they're doing it
to please their base and that to me is
even worse than doing it simply because
you hate someone and you're angry at
them as bad as that is this somehow to
me seems even worse our country is
teetering on the edge of something
potentially cataclysmic I believe and
these people are making a game out of it
making a game out of it it's sickening
and the thing is in this environment
here's what happens if you try to cut a
course through all of this if you try to
be consistent in your assessments of
things if you're not interested in the
basic throwing red meat thing if you try
to maintain a certain standard that you
apply consistently so that you don't end
up as a member of a mindless mob or as
one of the people whipping up a mindless
mob if you say I don't want to do that I
don't want to be in the mob I don't want
to be leading the mob I don't want
anything to do with that well if you do
that you're gonna be attacked by the
sociopaths and whack jobs on both sides
then what's gonna end up happening is
that you end up getting both mobs coming
at you which is why most people end up
retreating into one of the mobs because
they figure well then at least I have
some cover
from one of the mobs even if I'm in
another one
if you try anything the only thing
you're allowed to do now in this
environment is throw is throw red meat
that's all your letter anything more
nuanced than that will leave you
stranded it will leave you alienated and
that's been my experience especially
this week and my experiences is typical
there's nothing unique about my
experience at all just to be clear and
there are a lot of people who get the
backlash a whole hell of a lot worse
than I do but I thought I could just use
myself as an example because talk about
what you know I yes because I think it's
instructive or at least or at least
indicative it's over this past week and
before this this week but especially
this past week in the wake of the two
shootings I know and if you've watched
the show if you've read my pieces you
know that I've made a number of points
not all of them directly connected but I
think there are a lot of different
issues at play here with what leads to
the shootings and what we should do in
response to them there are a lot of
takeaways that one could well take away
from from all of this one of the points
that I made in response to the El Paso
shooting and I was saying this Sun on on
Twitter and you know after the shooting
and this is not revolutionary but given
that this was a white supremacist who
committed a mass shooting one of the
worst mass shootings in American history
targeting Hispanics you know I said that
white supremacism is stupid evil and
dangerous and obviously and there does
exist a certain collection a certain
group of white supremacist extremists in
this country and outside of this country
and members of that group have
perpetrated in the last few months three
of the worst mass shootings in history
Christchurch Pittsburgh and El Paso
those that's not even within a year
that's within what six you know six
eight months or something we've got
three of them with people with identical
ideologies basically these are white
supremacists driven by that ideology to
commit mass murder three in only a few
months that's a
and it's a problem it's not something we
could just overlook we can't pretend it
isn't happening because we're afraid
that if we acknowledge it the left might
somehow use it against us that's
cowardly I mean that's not just cowardly
that's several light-years beyond mere
cowardice to be shy about denouncing
white supremacy and to deny the fact
that white supremacist have murdered
mass amounts of people over the last few
months you know to be reluctant about
bringing that point up and that just
makes you a gutless little snake that's
a I mean coward doesn't even come close
to describing it and I had in as I was
talking about this over the weekend
again points being number one obviously
white supremacy is disgusting evil
dangerous stupid
number two the this group of people does
exist in the world they're not in a
majority thank God they're not anywhere
close to majority they're there in a
small minority they are fringe but
they're there and they're dangerous I
mean how many mass shootings do we need
is three not enough for us to say well
there's definitely a problem here
that we need to look at and talk about
happen do we need five ten I mean how
many is three not enough for us to say
yes but as I was talking about many
numerous conservatives on Twitter who
who told me though you're just sucking
up to the left saying this look at you
suck it up what you think that's what
sucking up to the left by pointing out
that we've got this group of people
murdering people and that's a bad thing
that's sucking up to the left no that's
just that's just being a normal person
that's acknowledging a very real problem
that's just being a human being that's
all that is
but at the head of the gutless snakes
speaking of gutless snakes enter
Nicholas J Fuentes Nick Fuentes is a
white supremacist in actual white
supremacist with somehow a following
online
which proves that the again is that
these people exist they're fringe
they're a minority for sure they are not
at all representative of conservatives I
don't even think they are conservatives
and I probably they would also tell you
they're not conservatives but they're
there
it's manera certainly there when tiss is
he's one of those guys who went to that
nazi tiki torch rally the one where a
woman was murdered by a neo-nazis one of
that one of those he's one of those guys
who went to one of those to that thing
and that's that's basically where he
stands well Fuentes here here is now
I'll show you I'll show you what in case
you don't not familiar with him here's
what Fuentes looks like here's forint
days I you know and I could only show
you a still image because he deleted the
video that I'm about to address or at
least he deleted the part of the video
that I'm going to address so I can't
afford for you because he deleted it
like a coward but on his little white
supremacist talk show on YouTube he
launched into a temper tantrum because I
said that white supremacy is bad because
I said as on Saturday
I said pub I heard already told you what
I said and I said that this guy this
white supremacist should be executed so
should the one in Dayton I've already
I've discussed numerous times over the
last few months my evolution on the
death penalty and yeah if you're a mass
murderer you should be executed for
intous didn't like that so he had a
temper tantrum reduced nearly to tears
and again because he's a gutless Punk he
deleted this tantrum he took it out of
his show but here's what he said he said
Matt Walsh Shabbos [ __ ] race traitor
that's anti-semitic if you're not
familiar with the with the link
anti-semitic lingo there a Matt Walsh go
erase traitor that's what and you have
to imagine that I'm foaming at the mouth
and nearly tearing up as I'm saying this
because this is this is that's you know
this is when to screaming it like like a
lunatic so Matt Wolf's Shabbos [ __ ] race
trader that's what it is folks I know
some people don't like us to use that
expression but it's totally true
throwing his own people under the bus
he hates white people nobody else talks
like that about their own people except
for white people and it's gross yeah
okay keep typing on Twitter calm
then in KeepCup toby on twitter calm
then he called me a gay slur starting
with f twice and then he another word
starting with P and then he and then he
says again race trader you work for Jews
okay so I work for Jews I'm a race
trader he says that a couple times gay
slurs blah blah blah I hate white people
and this all because I said that white
supremacism is a problem it's bad when
white supremacists kill people and white
and anyone who kills you know twenty
people should be executed now we're just
gonna skip past the fact that a guy
named Fuentes is a white nationalist
will skip past that part the idea that I
that I hate white people or that I'm
attacking my own you know here's the
thing Nick these are I'm not attacking
my own people these aren't my people if
you're claiming the El Paso guy is your
people then go ahead and do that
he's these days not my people he's not
my people just because of the color of
his skin that's not the way it works for
me may be the way we works for you but
not for me
the idea that I hate white people
because I specifically denounced races
to walk into Walmart and mosques and
synagogues and slaughter women and
children the idea that I hate white
people for being opposed to that it's
it's so delusional so insane so utterly
psychotic that I feel like I'm wasting
my time responding to it but I and and I
suppose I am but I also don't think we
can ignore this because there are people
out there who this is how they see the
world and these people are dangerous
I'll just say this and and unlike Nick
the brave went it's the freedom fighter
I'm not going to delete this or take it
down it's gonna stay on YouTube and so
anyone can see it let me say this to
four days you are a spoiled brat you are
a spoiled stupid brat who became a
neo-nazi troll for attention
you got into college and realized that
you could spit these neo-nazi talking
points and it would get you attention
and that's why you're doing it and I
know you and I know that you know that
about yourself you and I both know that
see man-to-man looking each other in the
eyes through cameras you know that about
yourself you know you don't believe half
of the crap you say I'm a race traitor
because I said that uh you know white
guy who kills people should be executed
you believe that because in order to
believe that you would have to be a
psycho you have to be literally
psychotic which I don't think you are
I'm not gonna give you that excuse I
think you know better but the ideology
that you promote that you advocate is
the exact ideology of three mass
shooters who have killed dozens of
people now it's true that people on the
left you know they're gonna they're
gonna try to take these mass shooters
and and and compare all conservatives to
them and say that they share an ideology
with all of us they don't they don't
share an ideology with me they share it
with you these are the kinds of people
who would call other whites race
traitors that kind of thing who are
worried about the Jews who are prone to
you know accuse someone of working for
the Jews no that's your crew and that
means not mine
the El Paso the El Paso shooters
manifesto is indistinguishable from your
ramblings I can't tell the difference
it sounds exactly the same to me now
here's the thing little Little Nicky one
of these days because you're a young guy
what are you 17 18 I don't know I mean
15s I don't with the mustache EULA looks
like it's your first mustache it's yeah
I mean it's it's looking good I'm not
gonna hate on the mustache and it's you
know it's a cute little you fret your
first attempt I get it but one of these
days Nick you're gonna grow up and
become a man which you aren't right now
one of these days you're going to grow
up and become a man and when you do
you're gonna look back with remorse and
embarrassment on the time you spent
advocating white supremacy and crying on
the Internet when someone criticizes
bigotry and mass murder that's gonna
happen in the future
you're gonna look back on you on
yourself using phrases like race
traitor and you're gonna be so
embarrassed and you're gonna go out
begging for forgiveness you know like
many of the prominent white nationalists
who have in just the last few years
renounced it and tried to pick up their
lives and salvage some credibility and
find and establish some distance from
the alt-right because they they woke up
from their stupor and they realized wow
this is so freakin stupid I look like a
like an idiot and at the same time I
have associated myself with some of the
worst people on earth and so a lot of
those former alt-right white
nationalists they're trying to distance
themselves and pick up their lives and
salvage some credibility and when you
begin that process which you will good
luck and I mean that but in the meantime
though I just want to emphasize that
your worldview is extremely extremely
extremely stupid
and you have aligned yourself with the
worst people on earth race traitor what
the hell is a race traitor my ancestors
were Irish okay yours were well I mean
your name is fondest okay and I don't
see how i betray you by thinking for
myself the fact that we have similar
skin pigmentations does not
automatically put us on some kind of
team together and by the way if your
ancestors had the same ideas about
racial purity that you do you wouldn't
exist so maybe cool it with the race
trader stuff big guy and be cool it with
that
you know the teams in America if there
are teams it's it's not divided by skin
pigmentation it's not it's not divided
by you know what color your skin is
that's that's not how that we divide the
team's anymore at least it's not how I
divide them now you that's how he that
is how you divide them so you are along
with being indistinguishable from
radical white supremacists who who kill
mass amounts of people you're also
indistinguishable from the race baiters
and the identity politics people on the
Left you're doing your own version of
that and when I see that on the Left I
say it's very very stupid and when I see
you with the USA it's very very stupid
as well because those aren't the team's
if you're an American citizen and you're
a decent human being if you're a legal
American citizen you're a decent human
being you value freedom and objective
morality and truth and those things we
have the same belief we have we have you
know the same fundamental priorities in
life then as far as I'm concerned we're
on the same team why would I care what
color the person's skin is this this
isn't some after-school special sermon
about about you know racial unity this
is just I literally don't understand why
you would care what difference does it
make
alright meanwhile and I've already spent
more time on that that I need to you
know for entice and his people they
represent a dying thank God a dying
ideology but the problem is as that
ideology dies as that worldview dies it
apparently is determined to take out as
many innocent people with it as it can
and so that's my that's my concern
meanwhile checking in with the other
side of the coin here Media Matters got
a hold of a clip of me from the show
yesterday they posted it online with
with the caption the Daily wires Matt
Walsh points to an overly feminine
influence on boys as a potential cause
for mass shooters now let me play a case
in case you missed the show yesterday
here's the clip that was on Jason
Campbell's jason campbell works for
Media Matters he's the one who posted it
to try to you know generate some outrage
against me and and and here's here's the
clip when when all boys have is the sort
of feminine influence now not all women
are like this but a mom is more likely
to say oh and you still don't you still
don't hit back the mom is more likely to
because she's you know she's she's the
feminine influence she's more focused on
the fact that her son is hurting he's
got the black eye that's what she's
focused on where as the father you're
you know you're worried about his
physical pain but your that's not the
main thing you're focused on you want to
know that he swing first did you win you
know that's gonna be one of your
questions boy needs that also he can't
just have the feminine influence it's
not healthy all right now so I think
that's that's part of it but yeah and I
have to stipulate this I shouldn't have
to stipulate it but I'm not look you
could have a boy who grows up with there
are many boys many millions who grow up
with no father in the house they play a
lot of video games and watch a lot of TV
they're on the drugs and they don't grow
up to become mass shooters okay that's
the vast majority of boys in that
category are not going to grow to become
mass shooters of course because for that
for that extra
dramatic step of becoming a killer
there's there's gonna be a lot more
needed but boys are still being put in a
disadvantage even if they don't end up
as mass killers there they are still
going to end up taking unhealthy risks
in some form they're still going to end
up finding unhealthy outlets for their
aggression in some form they're still
going to end up confused about who they
are and that is in some way going to
come out now I've gotten a lot of
backlash for this of course so it's been
it's oh it's been coming from both sides
like I was what I'm saying white
supremacists on wine left us on the
other I'm a race traitor a secret
liberal on one hand but I'm also a
sexist far-right extremist on the other
it must be a split brain thing have you
heard of those cases where someone has
split brain the two hemispheres of the
brain so they're two different people I
may be I must be that I don't know I
should go see a neurologist because I
either wise I'm not sure how it could be
all of those things at once but
apparently I am now normally what
happens is Media Matters takes an
out-of-context clip from a conservative
commentator they stir up the outrage
brigade and then the commentator
apologizes or clarifies or whatever I
will do neither of those things anyone
who wants to see the whole point that I
made in that which was the show
yesterday if you want to see it and that
that clip is part of a probably 20
minute monologue where I'm talking about
the problem of fatherlessness and how
fatherlessness might contribute to
certainly violence generally but also
mass shootings if you want to see the
whole the whole point I'm making which
is which is which is a a longer point
than that one and a half minute clip
would would would indicate you can go to
youtube and look at it you can see it on
iTunes or SoundCloud or whatever for now
though I'm comfortable letting it stand
and I do in fact believe that the
feminization of boys is part of the
problem not the whole problem not even
the main problem but it is a problem and
it's part of the larger problem we've
been talking about this week week I'm
crazy enough to think that you know we
should raise our boys to embrace their
masculinity to embrace themselves to
grow into that identity
rather then the other ideas having them
choose their own identity randomly when
they're three years old rather than that
because we know what their basic
identity is right we know that okay this
is a boy we have an understanding of
that they don't as very young children
and so our job is to help them embrace
and grow into that and figure out what
that means in the extreme cases when you
have a boy he's going around saying he's
a girl what he's what he's express what
he's really expressing is that he
doesn't understand who he is he's
expressing confusion and so our job must
be to cut through that confusion and and
and to lend some clarity to the
situation so yeah that's what I believe
Nach I'm not going to apologize for that
and I think this is one of those things
that most normal people intuitively see
is true the fact that yeah it's better
to have a dad in the picture
the fact that we are feminizing our boys
to a large extent sometimes literally
sometimes in the most literal sense
we're literally trying to turn them into
girls sometimes yeah I think that's just
obvious to a lot of people and
intuitively most people can see that
it's a problem but on the left
they are often scandalized by these
self-evident intuitive truths all right
let's let's take it down a notch before
we get to emails I wanted to mention one
other thing because I thought it was
funny so I need a let's pay it's been so
much heavy stuff this week but Time
magazine has an article with this is the
headline in time it I haven't read the
article I admit and I usually I'm the
first to complain about judging articles
based on that line but I think here you
can safely do that
the headline is we counted every line in
every Quentin Tarantino film to see how
often women talk that's the headline and
in the article I assume they give us the
results we're gonna count they
apparently they watched every Quentin
Tarantino movie with a with a notepad
and
paper and a pen a pen and just tabulated
the cumulative amount of minutes that
women characters spent talking in every
Quentin Tarantino movie and he said what
is he had nine movies now and his movies
are long too it's probably almost like
30 hours of movies they watched so they
could tabulate I don't know what the
results are like I said I didn't want I
didn't read the I didn't read the the
article I don't think it really matters
I mean maybe it could be fun to watch a
bunch of movies and arbitrarily quantify
certain things like maybe watch every
Christopher Nolan movie and tabulate how
many times people in green shirts say
the word the how about yeah I don't know
maybe maybe we could do that if we're if
we're arbitrarily quantifying things in
movies then why not that but this of
course is part of the why did they do
this well they did it because because
feminism has run out of things to do and
it hit a lot of time on their hands
that's the first reason but ostensibly
they were you know trying to this is all
part of the this whole idea that women
are you know not represented as much in
movies and that they're not given a
chance to talk this stretches beyond
Quentin Tarantino and beyond movies
generally this is something you hear
from feminists a lot that women are
reluctant to talk they're always being
interrupted by men and feminists paint
women as generally these sort of wilting
wall flowers who hang out in the corner
and are meek and mild and afraid to
chime in and say anything whether in the
real world or in movies and and this
again is just reveals that feminists are
living in a universe that I don't know
what universe are living in it's not
this one because I'm pretty sure I'm in
this universe and I don't recognize this
this is maybe the weirdest invention of
modern feminists is this concept that
women don't talk enough and are afraid
to talk and are constantly being you
know talked over by men that of all the
problems in the world I'm pretty sure
that's not on the
you know III think women generally do
this is not a criticism okay
women do a fair amount of talking and in
movies and in real life they do a fair
amount of it I'm pretty sure that if we
were to tabulate all of the time that
women in this country let's say in a
given day let's take all of the talking
that is done in real life on TV anywhere
in this country in a given day I don't
know this because I haven't counted it
but I'm pretty sure that we would find
that probably like 80% of the talking or
more is done by women it's it's I mean
it's at least equal but I'm it's
probably a lot it's it's it's probably
quite a bit unbalanced in favor of women
so this is its we're expected to believe
a dead feminists are so desperate to
find persecution that now they're
they're finding in here tell us what
women don't talk enough I mean certainly
you know I I I have a wife I've got four
sisters I've got I've got one daughter
and another on the way I've got like I
don't know nine or ten nieces lost count
I spent a fair amount of time around
women like like anyone has and yeah I
feel like they they hold their own in
the talking Department in fact it's you
one of the main complaints that you hear
from wives everywhere in the world is
that their husbands don't talk enough
let me ask you when was the last time
you heard that complaint from a man was
the last time you heard a man complain
that the women in his life don't do
enough talking that his wife was the
last time a man said to his wife you
know we don't talk enough we need to
talk more why don't you talk in the
whole history of human civilization has
any man ever uttered those words maybe a
couple but I have to think it's a it's a
rarity so this I I just look if women
are being oppressed in this country
personally I don't see it but if they
are being oppressed it's not here
it's not in the talking disparity
because that's in their favor so there I
were good there we really are all right
let's go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
let's see a bunch of emails chiming in
on the video game discussion from
yesterday I'll read a couple and this is
from Joseph says Matt I very much enjoy
your podcast so even with the email
being critical please keep that in mind
doesn't matter Joseph if you're
criticizing me it will hurt my feelings
so it doesn't matter you could try to
stipulate it all you want it's not gonna
save my feelings how dare you he says
let's be extremely generous to you here
and assume that video games cause 100
percent of mass shootings outside of
Muslim extremism all the rest of them
it's the one and only caused tally up
the number and there's been a couple
hundred deaths because of it sure any
death is too much I suppose but let's
compare to alcohol well be okay before
we I'll continue reading but you say
let's be generous to me and assume that
video games cause 100 sent of mass
shootings I never said my whole point I
never said the video that video games
cause any percent of mass shootings I
think if we're talking about direct
causes video games cause zero percent of
them so you say be generous to me by
assuming that makes it sound like you're
saying that I was arguing that video
games cause a certain percentage of mass
shootings I wasn't saying that in fact I
tried to be clear about that by
stipulating it over and over again that
video games do not cause mass shootings
I think that like any form of media they
are an influence they influence people
and so if somebody spends hours a day
years of their life playing video games
and and then they turn into a mass
shooter and we're looking at all of the
different influences that may have
contributed to it that's probably going
to be one of them but as I said it's
it's it's not even because of the
violence in the game it's because of the
isolation it's it's because it breeds
isolation and addiction that's the
danger of it which is also the danger of
TV and Internet and any form of media
okay
so he's going says let's compare to
alcohol alcohol is a substance you drink
it's a substance that you believe the
legal drinking age should be lowered
unlike video games there's actual
conclusive research confirming the
damages it causes it stunts brain
development and you think is caught it
causes it is the cause of about half the
fatalities on the road latest research
shows alcohol causing about eighty eight
thousand deaths a year on top of that my
father worked in law enforcement at a
County Jail for 33 years do you know
what type of people were committed
committing crimes abusing their spouse
and and kids let me give you a hint it
wasn't gamers it was people under the
influence of alcohol alcohol causes
broken homes not videogames on top of
that I'm sure you know the substance is
used as a social lubricant almost always
accompanied by people having premarital
sex by its very nature alcohol lowers
your inhibitions and judgment so you
have one substance that you like that
you will defend to the core which has
proven to cause children out of wedlock
addiction stunted brain development
lower inhibition fatal car accidents
broken arms poor physical health
thousands of deaths per year yet on the
other hand you have video games which
have no conclusive evidence whatsoever
to be an influencing factor in some mass
murders and this is what you rail
against continually why is it they rail
against video games and not alcohol when
one is clearly a more destructive force
in in the world than the other I don't
know but I can only assume it's because
you personally like alcohol you
personally do not like video games with
the extensive data available the
destructive nature of alcohol if you are
so inclined you could write a piece a
hundred times more convincing of its
toxic nature than you can of video games
but you're not so inclined so you don't
I don't what this email to be mistaken
for me being upset or mad at you like a
lot of people are hardly play games I
realize people aren't perfectly
consistent with all their stances and
actions I would just be interested to
know how you rationalize such a harsh
stance against video games with while
defending and almost promoting the use
of a substance proven much more
destructive okay all right there's a lot
here so I feel like I have to go through
this one by one so I'm sure I'm gonna
miss a couple of points you raised first
of all a small thing you say video games
don't cause broken homes I would argue
that they almost certainly do actually
probably not as I mean not as many as
alcohol does but all you have to do is
read some light my emails every any time
I talk about this which is rare I'll get
that in a second any time I talk about
this I hear from from
women wives who say that their marriages
have been destroyed because their
husbands just won't stop playing video
games all I do is play they they come
home from work they go and play video
games for five hours I don't even see
the kids this is a really common thing
it's goes to the addictive nature of
video games and I think it's one of the
reasons why some guys are so defensive
of it because they recognize that
they're doing this there are I don't
know what the number is okay Joseph but
there are certainly meant their husbands
who they they neglect their their wives
and their kids to play video games
that's a real thing just talk to women
they'll tell you it's it's unless
they're all lying it's a thing and yet
it does contribute the broken homes in
there it's I mean it's crazy to think
that it would that any guy would choose
video games over his family but some do
that's a thing it happens just like
there are guys who chose to choose
internet porn over their families there
are there are guys and women who choose
you know essentially choose social media
and Internet over their families because
they prioritize those things over their
family so sorry I would I would quibble
with that you go on to talk about the
dangers of alcohol I agree alcohol is
dangerous
well you all say I rail against video
games constantly I think I've done two
shows about video games I've written two
articles about video games maybe three
since I start in the last five years
I've written I don't know five hundred
articles three of them have been about
video games three and fight probably
more than 500 I don't even know how many
I I write every day so you know and I've
been doing this for five or six years so
you do the math hundreds of articles
three of them have been about video
games and joseph´s not the only email I
got saying why do you always talk about
this I always talk about it I've talked
about it a couple of times in years and
I've done I think what am I on I'm on my
300th show I think and two of them have
touched on video games two out of like
three hundred okay so I the say I
constantly talk about it is just not
true now you what but it's true though
that I have not written any articles
detailing the dangers of alcohol
I haven't done any show about the
dangers of alcohol I also have never
denied those dangers I've certainly
acknowledged them in many contexts many
times why haven't I done a show on it
well because it's it's it's not
controversial at all at all everybody
agrees that alcohol can be dangerous
that alcoholism is bad the drunk driving
is bad that people die from
I've never heard anyone dissing ever
deny that now Alka there are still
alcoholics who behave dangerously it's
so we all acknowledge it yet it's still
a problem so we need to address the
problem but what I do on this show is I
try to analyze and and offer commentary
on issues and I like to focus on issues
where there's going to be substantial
disagreement because if everyone agrees
I don't even see the point of saying it
what would be the point of me doing a
45-minute show where the my entire point
is it's bad to be an alcoholic you
shouldn't be an alcoholic don't drink
and drive
every single person who hears it is
gonna say yep I totally agree
uh-huh there's nothing to be said the
fact that video games that there are
that you know to me it is self-evident
that there's there's danger to
overconsumption of video games the fact
that so many people disagree to me means
that we need to talk about it there's a
reason to discuss it because there is
disagreement on the issue as far as not
wanting to criticize alcohol because I
like alcohol but that's just not true
again I fully acknowledge the dangers of
alcohol I don't deny it
and this idea that I'm reluctant to
criticize things that are close to home
for me is just not true my first show of
the week that everyone seems to have
forgotten about at least the people
upset about video games have forgotten
my first show of the week I was talking
about what are what are some of the
contributing factors to this was my
first show I didn't mention video games
I talked about the internet I am on the
internet right now I'm on the internet I
was I'm talking to you I'm on the
internet I make my living on the
Internet I spent a lot of time on the
Internet
I need people to be on the Internet to
make a living to feed my family it is as
close to home as they could possibly be
yet I have no problem criticizing it I
have no problem saying that the intern
as many dangers and even that look I've
written articles encouraging people to
stop using the Internet even if that
means they're not reading me anymore
it's good it's good for you I mean if
you were to never sign on the internet
again it would hurt me because I would
lose a listener and an end of you err
but it will be good for you
I encourage you to do it so I I have no
compunctions about criticizing things
that are close to home for me so I just
I think that that's just it's it's an
it's an invalid criticism it's not true
I do it all the time
I but I do think on the other hand it
seems to me that there are a lot of
gamers out there who when it comes to
games they they will not they will not
acknowledge any problem with it because
they like it that's how it seems to me
so I agree that that attitude of not
wanting to acknowledge the problems with
the things that you enjoy I agree that
that is a problematic to borrow a word
from from from our friends on the Left
it's a problematic attitude but I think
that attitude with with this discussion
is much more prevalent and obvious on
the pro gaming side from Gabe let's hear
from the other side of this argument
says on the topic of video games in
their potential effect on real life
violence I'd like to add my perspective
as both a lifelong passionate gamer and
as a veteran people are demanding
scientific evidence from you and there's
nothing more scientific in my experience
than Marine Corps training in it's no
coincidence that recruits are immersed
for three straight months and violent
speech and violent thought patterns even
outside of the actual combat training
example whenever we practice the drill
movement inspection arms my platoon
would scream a Boondock Saints quote
which is each day we will spill their
blood till it rains down from the skies
that's pretty badass quote though if to
admit desensitization is the clear
purpose of such training but it's a
necessary good thing in the context of
military service since I was old enough
to play them I've also loved violent
video games in a word they're awesome
and they're a part of what inspired me
to join the Marines in the first place
but if the Marine Corps uses direct
exposure to violent language and thought
patterns to train more efficient killers
good
- loving amazing Patriots but killers
nonetheless it would be insane to assume
that violent video games don't make it
easier to countenance and perhaps even
to commit violence in the same way crazy
thought
maybe parents should keep their violent
games away from the kids until their
brains and social awareness have
developed to the point that they can
more easily guard their own psychology
against dangerous stimuli at any rate
when you come into your rightful place
as supreme overlord the splendid and
righteous one would you allow me to keep
my violent games at least until my Swift
and deserved execution for keeping my
apartment at 78° Gabe you just ruined it
at the end there 68° Gabe 68° is the law
every every building in the country we
kept at 68 degrees year-round okay oh
man you were doing so well
and then you just signed your arrest
warrant right there but in actuality I
think you can expect clemency because
you agreed with me which which you know
in my in my tyrannical dictatorship that
is really the only law is you must agree
with me but so yeah I think the point
Gabe makes now see I know you're gonna
say this is because I'm biased and I am
and maybe it is because I'm biased but
to me this perspective from Gabe it is
more credible and some and more valuable
because he AB he is going against in a
way his own interests so he loves
playing games yet he's offering a
criticism of games so you can't dismiss
it as well he's just trying to justify
what he does he's doing the opposite so
to me that's always interesting when
people are willing to do that but when
all you're doing is closing your ears
and defending a thing you like to do
without even engaging with the other art
with with the opposing arguments that
it's just it's not credible it's not I'm
not saying that's what Joseph was doing
but there are people who have been doing
that and to me it's just not credible
this is interesting though that Gabe
would make these points and I think it
yeah to me it's just obvious look I gave
you the studies I said we could play
dueling studies and there are Studies on
both sides of this I also pointed out
from the methodology that there's there
are only a few ways methodologically to
do these studies and I think no matter
how you do
the conclusions aren't gonna be very
useful because it's going it's going to
rely most of the time on self-reported
data from people who are obviously
biased so we could do Studies on both
sides but as I said I think that's it's
a pointless exercise instead we could
just use common sense B obviously as
Gabe points out if you if if a kid is
wallowing in this kind of content for
years and years
clearly it's gonna desensitize him it's
the same thing with pornography now if
if someone has a steady diet of
pornography from the age of ten to
twenty five and then at twenty five they
become a rapist
are we gonna argue that the porn habit
was irrelevant completely irrelevant had
nothing to do it was just a coincidence
come on I mean obviously it's not
irrelevant but of course we're also not
gonna argue that the porn caused the
rape the rape because there are millions
of porn viewers out there who never rape
anybody and we all know that however
probably it's not irrelevant that's all
it probably was an influencing factor
among many others that led eventually to
this so if you yeah if you if you're if
you're stewing in this kind of content
it is going to desensitize you that's
it's it's it's human nature it's a
psychological reality that we get used
to things we we grow accustomed to
things we're very good at that which can
be good depending on what the thing is
it's good that we're able to adapt to
our circumstances but when the thing
we're growing accustomed to is violence
and brutality even if it's fictional
violence that's probably not good all
right let's see thought see if we had
one more here
we had a quite I can't find maybe I
accidentally deleted it before I before
I got it there was a question about oh
here it is this is from Chile and Chris
says if you claim that physical violence
is not is not okay against speech how
can you justify punching someone that
calls your girlfriend or wife a B word
I clearly would punch the heck out of a
guy that calls my girlfriend any word
like that however I do understand too
that words should be dealt with with
words and if someone calls me a stupid
racist [ __ ] I shouldn't be out there
punching them how do you how do you do
it to reconcile both ideologies you
support since I'm sure you would also
physically defend your wife if insulted
by another man yeah that's a good
question and this is why Chris if I
could call you Chris and I don't if you
need to hold that hold name Chilean
Chris this is why Chris I I don't say
that violence is never the answer
I don't think that's true I think that's
a blanket statement that's sort of silly
and childish obviously sometimes
violence is part of the answer I mean if
you think that there's ever in life ever
in the history of the world been a
justified war then you believe that
violence sometimes can be part of the
answer so I would never say that
sometimes violence is appropriate now
there are stipulations if you are
killing someone an innocent person
unprovoked not in an act of self-defense
but as an act of murder that obviously
is wrong despicable horrible evil
violence that's you know we should be
able to stipulate that and identify that
nuance and that distinction without
having to make some blanket statement
that it's never okay to use force under
any circumstance like it seems to me it
seems easy to say yeah you can use force
sometimes but not if you're killing an
innocent person that's obviously wrong
and even you know most of the time if
someone insults you if you hear an
insult it would be inappropriate to
respond physically but I'm not gonna sit
here and say that it's never appropriate
to respond physically to words I don't
think that's true and I think that if
you're out with your wife and someone
runs up and
verbally harasses her sexually harasses
her I think that you'd be perfectly
justified punching that person in the
face now this is where prudence comes in
because you might say to yourself
petting the situation well if I do this
I'm gonna go to jail and so that's not a
smart choice you know sometimes you
exercise prudence you have to measure it
and everything but in principle I think
for a man to respond with force to words
can sometimes be appropriate given the
situation
Jesus says turn the other cheek I think
it's a very important to note that Jesus
says turn the other cheek when someone
slaps you he's saying when someone slaps
you turn the other cheek he never says
if someone slaps your wife or your
mother or your child turn the other
cheek okay cuz then it's not your cheek
then turning of the cheek is just
there's another word for that it's
looking the other way while your family
member is being harassed or assaulted
Jesus didn't then advocate that he
didn't say that it's okay it's important
distinction crucial distinction turn the
other cheek when you were the one being
assaulted when your family's being
insulted when your wife your mother your
children no I don't think you do turn
yet you certainly don't I mean you
certainly respond in some way even if
not physically so it may if someone runs
up to you and calls you a bad name and
you just ignore them or turn the other
cheek that could be a sign of strength
it can also be a sign of cowardice
depending on the situation but that
could be said but if someone runs up to
your wife or a family member and
harasses them and you say nothing that's
not strength that's not you being the
bigger man that is you being scared
that's you being a coward and so yeah
that's how I would distinguish that all
right let's we'll go ahead and leave it
there thanks everybody for watching have
a great day
Godspeed hey everyone its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show America
has a problem with extremism people with
rigid ideas secluded with their own
becoming radicalized and increasingly
hateful and that's just the media will
talk about it on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin